so i've got this source of a wave right
here that's moving to the right at some
velocity so let's just say that the
velocity of the source
velocity
of a source
velocity of source let's call it v sub s
to
the right so we're really going to do
what we did in the last video but we're
going to do in more abstract terms so we
can come up with a generalized formula
for the observed frequency so
that's how far he how fast he's moving
to the right and he's emitting a wave
and let's say that that wave that is he
so let's say the wave that he's emitting
so the velocity
of
wave
let's call that
v sub w radially outward got to give a
magnitude and a direction so radially
outward
outward that's the velocity of the wave
and that wave is going to have a period
and a frequency but it's going to have a
period and frequency associated from the
point of view of the source and we're
going to do everything this is all
classical mechanics we're not going to
be talking about relativistic speed so
we don't have to worry about all of the
strange things that happen as things
approach the speed of light
so let's just say that it has so the
period it has some period of let me
write it this way
the source period which is the
the period of the wave from the
perspective of the source so the source
period
we'll call it t
sub source and the source frequency
which would just be we've learned
hopefully it's intuitive now it would be
the inverse of this so the source
frequency
the source frequency would be
we'll call it f sub s and these two
things are the inverse of each other the
inverse of the period of a wave is its
frequency vice versa so let's think
about what's going to happen
so let's say it time equal zero he emits
that first crest that first pulse so
he's just emitted it you can't even see
it because it just got emitted and now
let's go let's fast forward t seconds
let's say that this is in seconds so
every t seconds it emits a new pulse so
what first of all where is that first
pulse after t sub s seconds well you
multiply the velocity of that first
pulse times the time velocity times time
is going to give you a distance right if
you don't believe me i'll show you an
example if i tell you the velocity is 5
meters per second and let's say that
this period is 2 seconds that's going to
give you 10 meters the seconds cancel
out so to figure out how far that wave
will have gone after t sub s seconds you
just multiply t sub s times the velocity
of the wave and let's say it's gotten
over here
it's radially outward
so i'll draw it radially outward that's
my best attempt at a circle
and this distance right here this radius
this radius right there
that is equal to
velocity times time the velocity of that
first pulse
v sub w
v sub dot that's actually the speed i'm
saying it's v sub w radially outward i'm
this isn't a vector quantity this is
just a number you could imagine v sub w
times the period times t sub s
times
t sub s i know it's abstract but just
think this is just a distance times a
time if this was moving at 10 meters per
second
and it and if it and if the period is 2
seconds this is how far we'll have gone
10 meters after two seconds
now this thing we said at the beginning
of the video is moving so although this
is really outward from the point at
which it was emitted this thing isn't
standing still we saw this in the last
video this thing has also moved how far
well we do the same thing we multiply
its velocity times the same number of
time remember we're saying what does
this look like after t sub s seconds or
some period of time t sub s
well this thing is moving to the right
let's say it's here
let's say it's moved right over
here and we're going in this video we're
assuming that the velocity of our source
is strictly less than the velocity of
the wave some pretty interesting things
happen right when they're equal and
obviously when it goes the other way but
we're going to assume that it's strictly
less than the source is traveling slower
than the actual wave
but what is this distance remember we're
talking about let me do it in orange as
well
this orange reality is what's happened
after t sub s seconds you can say so
this distance right here
that distance right there i'll do it in
a different i'll do it in a different
color it's going to be the velocity of
the source it's going to be v sub s
it's going to be v sub s times the
amount of time that's gone by and i said
at the beginning that amount of time is
the period of the wave that's the time
in question so period of the wave
t sub s so after one period of the wave
if that's five seconds and it will say
after five seconds the source has moved
this far v sub s times t sub s and the
first wave so that first crest of our
wave has moved that far v sub w times t
sub s
now the time that we're talking about
that's the period of the wave being
emitted so exactly after that amount of
time this guy is ready to emit the next
crest he has gone through exactly one
cycle so he's going to emit something
right
right now so it's just getting emitted
right at that point
so what is the distance between the the
crest that he emitted t sub s seconds
ago or hours ago or microseconds ago we
don't know what's the distance between
this crest and the one that he's just
emitting well they're going to move at
the same velocity but this guy is
already out here while this guy is
starting off from the source's position
so the difference in their distance at
least when you look at it this way is
the distance between the source here and
this crest
so what is this distance right here
what is
that distance right there well this
whole radial distance we already said
the this whole radial distance is
v sub w the velocity of the wave times
the period of the wave from the
perspective of the source and we're
going to subtract out how far the source
itself has moved the force has moved in
the direction in this case if we're
looking at it from this point of view of
that wave front so it's going to be
minus
v sub s the velocity of the source times
times the period of the wave from the
perspective of the source
so let me ask you a question if you're
sitting right here if you're the
observer you're this guy right here
you're sitting right over there and
you've just had that first crest at that
exact moment that first crest has passed
you by how long are you going to have to
wait for the next crest how long until
this one that this this guy's emitting
right now is going to pass you by
well it's going to have to cover this
distance it's going to have to cover
that distance let me write this down so
the question i'm asking is what is the
period from the point of view of this
observer
that's right in the direction of the
movement of the source so the period
from the point of view of the observer
is going to be equal to the distance
that that next pulse has to travel which
is that business up there
so let me copy and paste that
copy and paste so it's going to be that
let me get rid of that shouldn't look
like an equal sign so let me delete that
right over there that shouldn't be
looked like it or a negative sign so
it's going to be this distance that that
next pulse is going to travel that want
to see getting emitted right at that
moment divided by the speed of that
pulse and or the speed of the wave and
we know it or the velocity of the wave
and we know what that is
that is v sub w
that is v sub
v sub w
now this gives us the period of the
observation now if we wanted the
frequency and we can manipulate this a
little bit let's let's let's do that a
little bit so we could also write this
we could also write this we could factor
out the period
of the source so t sub s we could factor
out and so it becomes t sub s times
the velocity of the wave
minus the velocity of the source
all of that over the velocity of the
wave and so just like that we've gotten
our formula for the observed period for
this observer who's sitting right in the
path of this moving object
as a function of the actual period of
this wave source the wave's velocity and
the velocity of the source now if we
wanted the frequency we just take the
inverse of this
so let's do that so the frequency of the
observer
so this is how many seconds it takes for
him to see the next cycle if you want
cycles per second you take the inverse
so the frequency of the observer is just
going to be the inverse of this if we
take the inverse of this whole
expression we're going to get 1 over t
sub s
times v sub w over the velocity of the
wave minus the velocity of the source
and of course one over the period from
the point of view of the source this is
the same thing
this right here is the same thing as the
frequency of the source so there you
have it we have our two relations at
least if you are in the path if the
velocity of the source is going in your
direction then we have our formulas and
i'll rewrite them just because the
period the observed period of the
observer is going to be the period from
the point of view of the source
times the velocity of the wave minus the
velocity of the source that's the
velocity of the source divided by the
velocity of the wave itself the
frequency
from the point of view of this observer
is just the inverse of that which is the
frequency the inverse of the period is
the frequency from the point of view of
the source
times the velocity of the wave divided
by the velocity of the wave minus the
velocity of the source in the next video
i'll do the exact same exercise but i'll
just think about what happens to the
observer that's sitting right there